okay let's look at a couple of clips you
know something kind of interesting has
started happening over roughly i'd say
the last three to four weeks and it
relates to this guy mike lindell the ceo
of mypillow a right-wing pillow
manufacturer who became friendly with
trump early in the pandemic started
showing up about how he's going to be
making masks and all these things i
don't know that they ever made any masks
but really since the election pillow as
we know him pillow's goal has been to
overturn the election results insisting
dozens of times that we're just days
away we're weeks away maybe at the most
a few months away from blockbuster
evidence coming out and just overturning
everything and they're uh he he claims
that they're suing all machines we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines all of my coffee machines are
now in witness protection as a result of
that so anyway this this thing has
happened where
clearly pillow is a laughing stock and
we all recognize that but over the last
three to four weeks for me and i know
also for some people in the audience
it started to get almost a little bit
sad where the guy seems kind of
genuinely unwell in a way and we know he
has a background of
drug addiction in his past
and generally speaking it from things
that he said we're putting together that
he seems to really believe this crazy
election stuff
he is spending a ton of money and not
even really seeing his family going all
around the country pushing it
and i and some others in the audience
have started to wonder
whether this is kind of becoming almost
more
medical in nature in some way
and then all of a sudden over the
weekend uh pillow spoke at the
experience the reawakening reawaken
america tour this is the event where
like eric trump will often speak at it
and sometimes i think ted nugent has
spoken we're going to look at some eric
trump clips a little bit later
and um
pillow now seems to have a very bad hand
tremor so i'm going to play this clip
for you it is visual you sort of hear
the tremor in his voice a little bit but
really what you have to see is he starts
switching the mic from hand to hand
because the mic itself is shaking and a
lot of people emailed me about this and
listen i mean something does seem to be
going on with the guy uh let's take a
look
thank you all
you guys keep me going i'll tell you
that
we're not giving up than anything ever
so there you can see in the left hand
this is the key moment where the hand is
just very very shaky when the mic is in
this hand
and then he seems to recognize it and
change the mic to the other hand so
uh and it's still showing what he was
what uh clay was talking about there and
i pray for everyone he was just talking
about um the um there was the interview
over next door and uh the guy uh all of
a sudden they're interviewing and i'm
trying to tell him what's going to
happen like i do
all the media and once again he took it
down a road here and made it about
something it wasn't and i ended the
interview very abruptly um now
understand that what he's saying also
does it it's just completely incoherent
and it wasn't and and you guys got to
realize normally that hand is just all
over the place i don't do that but i had
to get out here to speak
um normally i would sit there on the
phone with the media
for an hour hours at a time you could
call i have every media outlet i think
in my pocket from jimmykoska to uh
so anyway
it's it's something seems to be going on
here there seems to be some kind of
spiral happening and and it is getting
kind of sad i mean he has prior drug
issues we don't know anything about
what's going on right now who knows what
it could be and this isn't to make fun
of a medical condition nor a drug
addiction if either or both are factors
it's a reminder that this guy who has
been saying outrageous and untrue things
for over a year now about the 2020
election
corrosive
spending his money in a way that is
corrosive to democracy making also
throwing all sorts of innocent victims
under the bus
uh uh and we'll talk on the bonus show
today about how his count counter suits
against the voting machine companies
have been thrown out he's been doing a
lot of damage and he might genuinely be
unwell it's not an excuse for his
behavior but there's something sad about
watching him he does seem to genuinely
believe what he's saying and one one
wonders are there friends and family
here that could stage some kind of an
intervention because quite frankly this
doesn't seem to be good for him it
doesn't seem to be good for his family
which he claims he doesn't see anymore
and it's certainly not good for the
country one other clip uh i want to play
from from pillow from over the weekend
this was at a different event
he is also claiming that the january 6
trump riots were set up by the left to
deplatform trump and his supporters from
social media and that it's basically
becoming nazi germany here take a look
then they took them both because they
had a safety net and what was that that
was january 6. they had that all set up
so that what would happen would be a
historical day in history which was
january 7th
and on january 7th is the day
they tried to take our voice forever
they tried to turn out the lights on all
of your voices 1.2 million americans
were de-platformed including our great
president donald trump on vimeo youtube
sucker bucks facebook twitter
vimeo you name it all these platforms
were you were cancelled
well that was the day that they and i
put fear into everyone it was just like
nazi germany where everybody either had
fear
or you sat over here and you didn't want
to talk about it you know you didn't
want to talk out of fear and everybody
you know um
when the trump rioters committed all
that violence and destruction of
property
and then trump was banned from twitter
it didn't strike me like nazi germany
and i'm curious how many of you say you
know but the first thing my mind went to
was nazi germany
i don't think so and uh you might have
noticed oh this is an interesting detail
in the background you might see that
there's a bus and on the side it says
jesus guns and babies jesus guns and
babies and this was at a campaign
uh in forsyth georgia for some of the
upcoming
elections happening there this is
obviously very sad when it comes to
pillow himself
but we can't ignore that there's an
extraordinarily dangerous movement here
and so when we when we talk about these
issues
we want to find kind of a
reasonable medium where we don't say
this is just political disagreement with
people who are completely of sound mind
because many of them don't appear to be
of sound mind on the other hand we can't
say
this is merely a mental health issue
most people who have mental health
issues don't do any of this stuff
and so
we're trying to craft a more accurate
but also empathetic narrative
about what is a really scary and
unhinged movement that is sadly much
bigger than any of us would like to
admit but we have to be accurate and we
have to admit it's a pretty big movement
here in the united states
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping